CSR is the fancy word we give to when a
company gives to charity that's what it
is right you get to charity I give to
charity companies give to charity that's
a good thing but the charitable
contributions that you and I make are
just part of our desire to live good
lives and to serve other people right
and what what has ended up happening is
CSR has become sort of like the see we
are a good company because look look how
many hours we gave to our employees to
go you know build Habitat for Humanity
you know meanwhile you know we forced
them to work in these horrible work
conditions and you know they hate
working here and you know they're all
suffering from depression you know it's
it's not a it's not an equation it's not
like I can balance running a bad culture
with with giving more money to charity
of course they should continue to give
money to charity that's a good thing but
it should be in the context it should be
one of the many things that they do to
help advance their their cause which
they're also doing through their
corporate culture the products they sell
their marketing every aspect some of
which make money and some of which don't
so you know I like to compare a company
CSR program to to the rest of their
business and it's really funny you can
tell whether it's window dressing or not
just go to the website and number one
was our revenue they'll brag about their
the percent growth this year number two
is how many offices they have around the
world and like you see all these annual
statistics and of growth and then they
have we've given more to charity over
the past ten years you like the one
statistic that doesn't get updated every
year or every quarter and it's at the
end of the list as if to be like selfish
selfish selfish selfish see we're not so
bad so I concur I think giving to
charity is good but it should be an
obvious and balanced component of
everything that a company does
[Music]